hello and welcome to this video playing
I am never end Xavier Mourinho ruse okay
I'm a pawn up okay yeah let's play the
Queens gambit accepted in a little bit I
don't hate to know any details here I
think I they play night before here
right the system way it is normally
played okay I'm basically inventing
stuff here let's hope I'm not getting
killed stand playable
might be a bit slow yeah okay probably
it's not that bad
you
okay yeah hmm i don't want to play age
six and i don't want to play AG six yeah
okay maybe maybe g6 rather age six looks
like it invites some kind of pawned some
Parker no sacrifice too much what about
this queen bee one night takes a to
start a tactic okay I can take a to now
right or not to see have something there
I don't see it let's take be three maybe
ok anyway um p aight i guess to d8
always got here I am Scott Bishop age 6
I need the ATM it might not be so bad
him if I get shipped you feiven okay he
can trade this
hmm yeah I'm not happy with this
let's see when a temple here at least
the moment tempo is wrong but at least
the Queen has to move again okay he
might see half the rook lift yeah maybe
his look lifting already
yeah last thing much I can do if he goes
on the Third Reich after go f6 and kind
of try to weather the storm
maybe I can also take I mean rook h3
still can go go Kate it's not such my
ads it's mater it is made ok then I have
to do this this move not happy about it
but
Bishop's is 696 mmm stat convincing
roop checks 27 should should still work
or can he go rookie sex rookie 6 f ed
hanging by a thread but might work f 95
though rookie 695 is disturbing well
it's also good for white maybe not
losing our straight away
yeah pretty well what the heck it's hard
not to take 33 and it takes on f6 IE
wins wins ton of porn Sam check check
check
now ff7 is winning f7f 7 and normal
member debgen time working I didn't see
it might still be lost amazing
he had a one mover after totally are
playing me
check I didn't see that great and now
I'm losing again I cannot believe this
nonsense I really handle you go
unbelievable blah resigns yeah yeah yeah
yeah I'm meeting myself him I'm just an
idiot too late yet but okay I mean he
really had to yet he deserved to win but
in some way because he really played
that that part of the game very nicely
but Guerin she's not winning this kind
of position you might as well stop at
this game check check check Jay I was no
such f7 it's just just a simple tactic
Queen takes root g3 can just resign him
over chats that he went down again yeah
I'm winning and very simply actually
winning ok need a break thanks for
watching